[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's just seven weeks since the last
conservative leadership contest but like
Groundhog Day here we are again we'll
know who will take over from this trust
as prime minister within days possibly
just one maybe even today where she
sunak is way out in front he's already
got the 100 MPS needed to make it onto a
ballot but the question now is who if
anyone will join in my voice Johnson
flew back to Rally supporters as
conservatives watched on with either
excitement or alarm but Johnson and
sunak held talks last night with rumors
of a deal being struck Penny Morton is
the only other Contender but it looks
like she may struggle to get over the
line so a coronation or a contest that
could yet inflict more wounds on a
deeply damaged conservative party we'll
try and find out with our guests this
morning
on the show with All Eyes of whether
Boris Johnson will run again we'll talk
to the Northern Ireland secretary Chris
Heaton Harris who is supporting the
former prime minister Damien green was
the first Secretary of State in
effective Deputy PM under Theresa may he
is now Bennett backing penny mordant
Steve Baker led the brexiteer cause as
chairman of the influential ERG group of
Tori MPS he's now a minister and will
also be joining us live
and the first order of the day for the
new PM will be dealing with the public
finances so we'll talk to the former
commercial secretary to the treasury and
Goldman Sachs Chief Economist Lord Jim
O'Neill and for labor we'll be talking
to the shadow leveling up secretary Lisa
nandy
foreign
[Music]
to that contest shall we for the
conservative party leadership Scenic
already has more than 120 declared
supporting MPS you've also had some
crucial backing from the right of the
party yesterday including both Lord
Frost and Kenny badenark now as former
chairman of the ERG group of brexiter
Tory MPS Steve Baker Will's big
influence in those circles he's now a
minister in the Northern Ireland office
and joins us now thank you very much
good morning
I feel like you were one of the few
conservative MPS who it's been quite
difficult to predict who are you going
to back in this race and you back to
sports Johnson back in 2019 at the last
what race you back Liz truss via Zoella
Braverman where's your vote going this
time this time around I'm very proud to
back Rishi snack and why is that that
he's going to deliver competent capable
professional government that we can rely
on if above all what we need is
stability we need professionalism we
need to move this country forward from a
position of great difficulty and rishi's
the right guy to do it last time you
know you supported solar Braverman you
then switch your vote to Liz truss I
mean it felt a little bit like that's
kind of anyone but Rishi so what's
changed no that's not the case so when
we got down to Rishi versus Liz I felt
we had two fantastic candidates to offer
to the membership I was backing Liz
because that was the choice which Sue
Ella and the Euro Skeptics made I was
proud to back Liz but realistically if
you look at the summer I didn't campaign
very hard and that was because I was
very happy with either candidate and the
truth is that it was quite a marginal
decision for me and I'm very proud to
back Rishi this time okay now everyone
is talking about Boris Johnson it feels
like he is perhaps the biggest threat to
Rishi student right now when you're
flying back from his Caribbean uh
holiday will you or won't you run looked
in late night talks with Rishi sunak do
you think he would be a good prime
minister second time around there's a
lot of love out there for Boris Johnson
and I respect that I mean I've been a
big fan of Boris Johnson so many times
but this isn't the time for boris's
style I mean I'm afraid the trouble is
because of the Privileges vote Boris
would be a guaranteed disaster there's
going to be a vote before the House of
Commons on this issue of privileges
whether he worked deliberately misled
the house in that vote it's guaranteed
there'll be a large number of
conservatives who will refuse as they
see it to lay down their integrity to
save him and at that moment his
Premiership will collapse now the best
argument I've heard for dealing with
that is having the vote on the first day
but that relies on people believing that
other MPS think like they do that you
don't vote against a new prime minister
that isn't what will happen 62 MPS
resigned from from his government over
the Pinscher Affair which in the end
whatever one thinks about it was an
issue of conduct and character well
those same MPS are not now going to go
like Lambs through the division Lobby so
at that moment that there's a vote in
the House of Commons on privilege his
Premiership would collapse it's a
guaranteed nailed on failure and we
cannot allow it to happen so you think
that a sizable number of conservative
MPS would actually vote to say that he
misled one Member of Parliament rang me
on Friday to say that they would rather
lose the whip than vote for Boris
Johnson in that vote that and there's
Vic why because they think they're going
to lose their seats and they'll need to
make a living and in order to make a
living they'll need their reputations
and this is why they'd rather lose the
whip than vote for Boris in that
division so I'm sorry voters out there
love him and he's undoubtedly a
wonderful man he lights the room up when
he's in the room but unfortunately he
doesn't have that you know meticulous
compliance with tedious rules he just
doesn't do it and it's caught up with
him and and I'm afraid whatever people
would like to be true we need to just
ruthlessly face the truth as it is and
the truth as it is is when that vote
comes which it will his Premiership
would implode and this country cannot be
afford to be back here in a couple of
months how would you vote in that vote
well it depends what exactly what the
vote is but I'm committed that whoever
wins this contest I will give them
absolutely all the support I can because
it's in the National interest to do so
but equally I'm not
I'm not willing to lay down my Integrity
for Boris Johnson I'm not and
um we'll just have to see what any vote
is but really I want Rishi to win and I
want conservative members to please
engage with this reality and I know
people don't
people love Boris and there'll be people
out there leaping to social media to
call me all sorts of names under the Sun
but that's not important to me what's
important is how this country works out
in fairs if Boris is in charge his
Premiership will implode and we'll be
back here and I know look we haven't
seen the details of the vote the
privilege committee you know they
haven't done their report yet but you
can't rule out voting against him then I
can't rule it out no but look the truth
is if the details aren't really
important this isn't actually a legal
court case this is about the politics of
whether or not people think that Boris
Johnson said or when Boris Johnson said
all the rules had been complied with and
Etc whether he worked knew that actually
they hadn't been and the trouble is
there's so much evidence out there I
think the public have made their minds
up and apart from anything else it's
just too easy for his opponents the
labor party the SNP to absolutely make
hay over this and in those when in those
circumstances when everybody's inboxes
are filling up when the evidence can be
seen by everyone it's just inconceivable
that those members of parliament will
support Boris now his supporters at
Boris Johnson supporters say look he is
the guy with the Mandate he won that
election in 2019 he won all of those
seats many of them who had never voted
for the conservatives before
you've already asked the public to
swallow one unelected prime minister can
you really do the same with another I
really wish we weren't in these
circumstances I really wish we weren't
Liz truss made a mistake she went too
hard and fast she said that she's
apologized I really regret it I could
not have foreseen this would happen but
what I can now foresee is that the best
person to be prime minister of the UK is
Richie sunnock I wish we weren't in
these circumstances but it's Rishi and I
I think that he will accept that the
only set of policies we can carry
through are the ones in the manifesto
and I would expect that Rishi will
choose to use that mandate to press
forward the public don't like elections
and the idea that we should go straight
into election now really is for the
birds we need to give stability to the
market sort out the public finances post
this debacle and move on do you think
Boris Johnson should pull out of the
race then I think it would be
technically in I suppose but yeah I
think it would be for the best if Boris
did something big and statesmanlike I
mean if he wants to come back as prime
minister he would need to do it after
this privileges issue is settled I think
he'd make an amazing chairman of the
party everybody knows he's got huge
character Charisma he lights up any room
he's in make him chairman of the party
he can leave the campaign he confront
this government but he can't be what we
can't do is have him in as prime
minister in circumstances where he's
bound to implode taking down the whole
government with him and we just can't do
that again we know of course that Boris
Johnson and Richardson like hell talks
last night so far everyone's been very
tight-lipped about what those talks
actually uh were about I don't suppose
you've got any intelligence for us I
haven't though so that would obviously
be very big news and at the moment until
I've come on your program I'm not on the
campaign so you know I haven't been
briefed but I have spoken to Rishi
several times and I'm confident he'll
want to make sure he really does unite
the party and that's why for example
Simon [ __ ] and I on the other end of
the spectrum on brexit he and I have
written an article should be out as
we're speaking saying that we're coming
together behind Rishi and that we both
agree that the current policy on the
Northern Ireland protocol must be
continued and I think this is another
absolutely crucial Point whoever wins
this contest the only policy that can be
successfully carried through on Northern
Ireland is the one that we have
and everyone should understand that
because if if say Rishi doesn't or Penny
didn't carry through that policy the
Euro Skeptics would implode the
government there's absolutely no doubt
they've been very quiet but the Euro
Skeptics really care about this issue of
the whole UK leaving the jurisdiction of
European law and again whatever anyone
else may think that my colleagues like
friends like Bill cash and Mark Francois
and John Redwood they are not going to
tolerate any diversion any equivocation
on this point so whether it's Rishi or
Penny or Boris the same policy must be
carried forward on the Northern Ireland
protocol and I'm very pleased that
actually Simon [ __ ] and I have United
around this point quite different
politicians yeah but not that you
Simon's been very generous to me he's
recognized that I have taken some big
hits
in the apology that I gave to try and
change the negotiating Dynamic and the
friendship between us and Ireland and
it's working it's that's great but I
didn't just speak of humility I also
spoke of resolve everyone needs to
understand that the legitimate interest
of unionists is to end the jurisdiction
of EU law in Northern Ireland now that's
the hardest problem we need to solve but
we will not have devolved government in
in Northern Ireland until it's done that
means we won't be celebrating the 25th
anniversary of the Belfast Good Friday
agreement this is big stuff and everyone
involved needs to understand we can
offer both friendship humility we can
make apologies where they're needed but
in the end we've got to end the
jurisdiction of EU law in Northern
Ireland do you have have you had any
assurances from Rishi sunak that he is
going to follow through on what you want
to see yes I have I've spoken to him I
think three times in the last 24 hours
and I'm absolutely not concerned that
Rishi will follow through as he said in
public during the summer campaign he
will follow through on the current
policy but again no one should be in
doubt about this if Simon [ __ ] and I
can agree that the current policy needs
to be carried forwards then the EU and I
hope they'll hear me the EU should
understand there's not going to be a
change of policy you say that if he
doesn't
will effectively
you know well yeah and this is me just
observing I mean people
should look at recent history and
understand that in similar circumstances
the same effect will happen we know what
a Boris Johnson government will be like
we know how members of parliament will
vote if the privilege when when the
Privileges issue comes up and we know
how eurosceptics will will respond if
they feel betrayed over the Northern
Ireland protocol we just know how they
will and if this is not an issue for me
I don't ever want to be any part of any
kind of rebellion ever again I've done
enough of that for seven years I don't
know quite a lot of it but but the point
is what I'm trying to do this morning I
have done a lot I'm afraid but what I'm
trying to reflect on here is that
irrespective of what I think those
eurosceptic colleagues who I know and
love like like brothers and sisters
they were absolutely not tolerate any
Divergence from what we've said we're
going to do and again look at the recent
past again it doesn't matter whether
people like it or not they will do what
they will do and that is they will bring
down any prime minister who doesn't
deliver on this issue now I've got to
ask listross has been the shortest
serving prime minister ever you know
we've had an entire budget jumped yeah
emergency action by the bank of England
to stop Iran on pensions mortgage costs
spiraling yes you know Labor's now
leading by over 30 points in the polls
and you backed her at the last election
you've also served you know four hours a
government Minister you know do you take
any personal responsibility for what
we've seen over the last few months I
certainly feel personally responsible
for helping her become Prime Minister I
did some work in the Parliamentary phase
and some work
um in the phase in the country but I
really don't think I can have been
expected to foresee that she would go as
hard and as fast as she did I wanted as
I said earlier I thought they were both
fantastic candidates and I think
actually that Liz and rizview wanted
this at want and wanted the same
destination I mean I have discussed with
Rishi several times the big problem in
the public finances in the long run but
um I wanted Liz Liz's change of
Direction but I'm afraid you when you're
trying to shift a super tanker you can't
fly in like Superman and hit it at Mac 2
you just go through the sides and punch
a hole and that's what she's done
um so yeah I do accept there is some
responsibility but equally I was not in
the treasury I didn't sit down with her
and quasi and do this budget and I
remember standing there as we all heard
him make his statement and unlike a
normal financial event it was largely
heard in silence because I would think
we all could understand this is spending
too much money and cutting too much tax
so you know I didn't foresee that
happening okay now just to finish this
is something else I have to ask you made
a few headlines this week when krishnam
Guru Murphy uh called you a four letter
word that I definitely can't repeat on a
Sunday morning which sort of picked up
on a audio feed yeah at channel 4 news
and he's been disciplined have been
taken off air for a week do you think
that's an appropriate action well it's
really a matter for channel four I've
accepted his apology and for me that's
the end of it and God bless him since
it's a Sunday morning God bless him to
be fair to him I was absolutely tearing
strips off him in a live interview
that's because they told me it was a
pre-record down the line and I felt his
questions were poor once and I was
trying to deliberately give him answers
he couldn't use in a pre-record but
unfortunately they put me live on air
when telling me it was a pre-record and
the result was that I was tearing strips
off him live on air so I'm not surprised
that his blood was up and I forgive him
and that's the end of it okay uh that
very good thank you very much for being
on the program there at Stevens
revealing he's going to be backing Rishi
sunak in the race to be the next prime
minister
now just a day before the deadline for
nominations penny mordant is the only
publicly declared contender in the race
to be the next prime minister although
of course all the talkers about Boris
Johnson and Rishi sunak but the leader
of House of Commons appears to be
struggling to hit the 100 MPS needed
she's currently on around 23. she's also
lost some important backers from her
last run at the leadership well Damien
green was effectively Deputy Prime
Minister under Theresa May he's pledged
his support to Penny Morton he joins us
now thank you so much for being on the
program good morning so why Penny Morton
what because I think she's the best
candidate to unify the party and looking
at the country in the end is what
matters in this what we desperately need
is a period of calm competent stable
government and to do that you need a
United party and Penny is a candidate
who is attracting support from all wings
of the party you've just done an
interview with Steve and he was talking
a lot about Euro Skeptics and brexities
and Penny of course was a very strong
support daughter of brexit I supported
remain so you know this is a visible
sign that penny is the best place to all
the candidates actually to bring a very
fractious party together and and that
but that's worth it in itself but
actually what I care most about is the
country and unless we have that kind of
stable Unified Government then we're not
going to be able to stabilize the
country we've got a difficult period
ahead and I think that calm stability is
what the next government should aim and
Penny would provide that you say she's
attracting support from all wings of the
party I guess the problem is is it
enough support you know because you know
has she got the numbers how many MPS is
your now I mean well there are a a lot a
lot more than 23 because a lot of a lot
of colleagues are are not saying for
various reasons I wouldn't criticize
them for that
um but it's it's multiples of 23. I
think where would you we're confident of
I I won't reveal numbers partly because
they you know they change but they are
they grow by the hour but I I'm
confident that the penny will get over
the line tomorrow do you think she'll
get over 100 yes okay and so no question
of her pulling out today then rowing in
behind another candidate she's in it no
no she she is in it to win okay um you
um I just wonder that you know you're
talking about unity and the important of
you know of what the country needs
stability Unity with that in mind
is it not in the National interest for
Penny to show that unity and row in
behind another candidate if it is going
to be difficult for her you know
potentially to go on and win this
contest I don't think so because the
other uh a I think she'll win uh but B
uh you know we have a process and if
it's all stitched up Behind Closed Doors
by
big figures at Westminster then our
party members will feel cheated um we
you know we do have this two-stage
process and I think it I think it's a
sensible Innovation that we have this
indicative vote so we will know as MPS
who's ahead but if the party members
might feel a little bit bruised anyway
because you've effectively told them
that they got it wrong last time well we
I mean we haven't told them that I mean
it did it did go wrong you know Liz
admitted mistakes it was it's been a a
terrible few weeks
um and and she stood down but um I think
what in this uh context what we do need
is is to respect the process and if it's
an Evidence stitch up as I say I think
our party membership uh will be pretty
disgruntled about that and that would be
a bad way for a new prime minister to to
set out on the journey you are talking
about the the Optics of a stitch up and
how people would react to that you know
there are obviously reports of Boris
Johnson and Richie sunac having talks
and last night do you think that that
kind of potential deal making could be
seen as a Stitcher well I don't know and
I think none of us knows what happened
at those talks or what was discussed or
indeed whether they've stitched anything
up we you know we don't know but I think
the fact that we we are talking about it
in those terms suggests the danger of
that that if they turn around and say
right you know the two of us have
decided what's going to happen to the
country then uh you know perhaps you
know many of my colleagues and certainly
the party members and possibly the
country as well will think hang on
that's not the way this is supposed to
work what do you think of the idea of a
Boris Johnson prime minister round two
well I think we we saw what happened
last time and how the government sort of
literally fell apart uh with you know 60
odd uh resignation so uh I I you know I
just don't think it would work and I
think particularly not at this time I
think we all know that there's this
standards committee uh investigation
going on and as long as that's going on
um there is the possibility of if if he
became leader again then in a couple of
months time we'd all be here again and
absolutely we should not put the country
through that
now it's the second time of course that
Penny Morden ran for the leadership uh
she I think came third last time and
fell short backless trash this is what
she said about Liz truss at hustings in
August who can lead who can deliver who
does have that bold economic plan and
Nation needs I've seen enough to know
who that person is and that is Liz Truss
if Penny Morden genuinely believed that
Liz trust had the Bold economic plan our
nation needs what does that say about
her judgment well I think I mean a
majority of people supported Liz I I
didn't I voted for Rishi in in that
phase having supported penny in the
previous couple of rounds
um and you know we had a discussion
between two candidates
um and you know Liz herself admits that
you know she had an economic plan but
tried to do it too far too fast with the
terrible consequences we saw uh in the
markets because as you say but you know
Penny Morton sat in the cabinet and she
signed off on measures of the budget
well I think I think one of the things
we do know is that the cabinet weren't
consulted about about that budget that
it was it was agreed between Liz and
quasi
um and then and then announced basically
so I I don't hold the she didn't push
the cabinet responsible she didn't stand
up to Liz transtitute she sat in the
cabinet she backed the plants well I
mean the the cabinet I think met
literally three times uh in its whole
period so I think trying to blame
members of the cabinet for what's
happened over the past two months is
actually unfair just you know for
various reasons uh they they weren't
meeting you know for obvious reasons
given what else was happening uh in the
world but I think uh where we are now
then we need someone who who does share
the overall vision of a lower tax
smaller state but who recognizes the
reality that the most important thing is
to stabilize the economy uh to make sure
that Britain is a credible player in the
world again and Penny has already taken
steps she said she would leave Jeremy
Hunter's Chancellor I think that's a
very important step forward we've seen
that Jeremy with all his experience has
stabilized the pound stabilized the
guilts market so that is a very strong
message to send to the outside world in
the end although this is an internal
party election it's what happens in the
outside world that's going to decide on
the success of the next prime minister
and the next government and Penny's
already taken a significant step
forwards to that and it's interesting to
talk about about Penny's pennymordans
planned because I guess the criticism
that some MPS have is they just don't
know that much about what her vision is
about what she stands for you know I
remember that the last leadership
election in Duncan Smith telling me he
doesn't know what Paddy Morden has
achieved in government Lord froster when
he worked with her she wasn't always
visible sometimes I didn't even know
where she was is she a bit of a
submarine yeah I think I think that that
last criticism is particularly unfair
and I can say that with some Authority I
was Secretary of State for working
pensions when Penny was the disabilities
Minister and I didn't know her very well
when I went went into that job and I was
tremendously impressed both by the the
effort she put in the work she put in
and what's a very difficult brief
um but also the imagination she showed
she she revived the disability confident
campaign and there are tens of thousands
of people with disabilities in work
today who wouldn't have been had she not
done that so I so she's a very very
effective operator and in terms of the
vision
um she she has if you like and Orthodox
conservative Vision in a patriotic
Vision that says that we want to provide
opportunity for people we want to make
sure that the public finances are sound
and we want to make sure that Britain
can pay its way in the world can act as
a big player in the world and can do
that while trying to keep the state
under control spend every penny of
public money effectively so it's an
orthodox conservative Vision but but
that's what the conservative party
stands for it's interesting listen to
what you just said there about you know
opportunity about patriotism about
public finances I mean you could imagine
we're actually seeing that saying
exactly the same thing you know what's
the dividing line what's the reason that
people should back penny more than other
than the front runner well I think that
the the I mean the difference is that of
all the candidates uh well and there
aren't very many but but of the three of
them penny is the one who people will
instinctively rally around you know
we're already talking about the
possibility of the other two doing a
deal to try and unify the party Penny
doesn't need to do deals to unify the
party and stabilize the government
because of what she stands for and
because of the work she's done she can
do that herself and that I think makes
her the strongest candidate just very
quickly if she doesn't make it I know
you think she will will you be backing
Rishi neck again uh I will I will see
what happens but I'm not anticipating
that so I haven't thought about it yet
fair enough thank you very much for
being on the program today Damien green
uh there
right well as we have been discussing on
the show today Rishi sunak and his
former boss Boris Johnson held talks uh
lasting for hours last night now we
still don't know what was discussed
whether Boris Johnson has the numbers to
get on the ballot paper either so let's
try and find out shall we with someone
who knows the former prime minister well
the current Northern Ireland secretary
and the former Chief whip Chris Heaton
Harris who joins us now thank you very
much for being with us so you're backing
Boris Johnson just explain to us why
um well because he's a vote winner he's
got a mandate from the last general
election
um and I know from the reaction that my
another my friend friends are MPS who
went out canvassing yesterday got on the
doorstep that he is still a vote winner
today he's the one person labor fears
you know I'm really happy to have you on
the program because you know I know that
you are you know close to Boris Johnson
you served as his chief whip you
delivered him the difficult news last
time when you told him that you believed
the game was up so I feel like you know
if anyone's going to know where his head
is at maybe you can help us on that
um is he really gonna run
uh yeah I think so I mean I'm calling
for I really am calling for Instagram
I'm trying to work out the um uh uh you
know the numbers and I think the numbers
are actually Sophie we do have the
numbers just so you know um everybody's
speculating but the Ricky Camp knows me
up the numbers the penny Camp knows we
have the numbers so
um that's not um uh an issue um and this
is a time when we need a big player like
Boris in our politics so
um I think he will
um you know you say that you have the
numbers uh over 100 MPS that's what
we've been briefed as well but obviously
the the declared backers are much much
lower than that so you know we just have
to take your word for it is it a bit
like saying you know I have got a
girlfriend but you wouldn't know her she
goes to a different School
um no I mean I so the one thing I was
relatively good at as Chief whip was
numbers and
um we definitely have uh enough uh
numbers to get um well we've already
booked the appointment with block uh Bob
Blackman the uh Secretary of the 1922
tomorrow so yeah we've got the numbers
why are they so shy at being named then
um I'm not sure they're particularly shy
I mean there's some people who are uh in
government positions uh who um
uh and there are some people who might
be whips or uh on the 22 executive or uh
you know in positions where they don't
want to come forward but they don't have
to I mean only two people actually have
to be named on the nomination paper and
it uh and in the votes it's a secret
palette so
um I guess you can say a secret about it
as part of democracy and um nominations
similarly
the reason I'm asking about the numbers
is because obviously he hasn't declared
yet we haven't got a hundred uh public
uh backers I'm just trying to work out
the seriousness of this leadership
campaign you know he's kind of flown
back dramatically from the Caribbean
he's called up James Doddridge his
allies say I'm up for it dudders in you
know sort of typical exuberant form but
you know I can't work out exactly whose
campaign team is whether he's going to
declare who the 100 backers are we all
kind of falling into you know the great
Boris Johnson soap opera again I mean
are you have you spoken to him yeah I've
spoken to him and
um I I yeah well I think at this point
in time he's he's um Keen to see what
the Parliamentary party thinks uh you
know he he can be he is actually
um a great unifier he is a great
campaigner and he is someone who um has
a solid sense of what the country wants
um to hear and what the country needs to
happen so um yeah I mean yes he flew
back yesterday oh just be quite Frank
none of us expected this to happen at
all
um you know it was one of those weird I
I've never had quite I've had plenty of
weird times in my recent political
career but it was one of those very
weird moments
um
uh this week where uh I I did not expect
this trust to uh to resign on Thursday
um so lots has happened in a very short
period of time and the fact that we've
got the numbers after such a short
period of time with no campaign with
very little organization and
realistically uh just a few people
calling around demonstrates to me the
support for Boris Johnson that's in the
Parliamentary party also demonstrates to
me uh the the amount of email and and
social media traffic that we're all
getting now demonstrates to me that he's
really popular in the country too
uh you he had talks with Rishi sunak
last night everyone's been very
tight-lipped about what's happened we
don't know what happened you say that
you've spoken to him do you have any
steer on what did actually go on last
night
um I I know they had talks but you'll
have to give me I was doing something a
bit more social with her nephew's 21st
birthday
um last night so I
um uh I feel like I got up a bit early
just to be on on here so if you because
I I had a very good fun time with my
nephew last night okay well we
appreciate the early alarm uh in that
situation and do you think if Rishi
sunak offered him a job in his cabinet
that Boris Johnson would accept it or is
he only interested in the top job no I
mean to answer your question seriously
the last question seriously I mean I I
was really pleased that um that they had
talked so I honestly don't know what
transpired from those talks
um and I will be speaking uh to Boris uh
quite shortly and I'd like to these
things
um I I think it's really important that
the the party unifies and come and comes
together and I really do think it's
important that the country gets the
message that we are serious about
governing and we are serious about
sorting out the economic situation we
find ourselves in that has trained to
change so dramatically and such short
period of time that we're serious about
dealing with the international factors
that contribute to that that we have a
leader that's going to be unbelievably
strong when it comes to supporting
Ukraine and facing down uh Putin that we
are an understanding of the economic
situation we find ourselves in and so
yeah I I want those talks between
um Rishi and Boris to continue because I
think and indeed to involve Penny
because these are all big players in our
future and if they came together I think
it would be a dramatic
um turn for the better for us all
you're talking about birthstones for
being an election winner you talk about
his action on Ukraine you could talk
about his understanding of the economic
situation and I really want to ask the
question that I actually think is really
important because we get sucked into all
this drama what actually is the economic
strategy that Boris Johnson is running
on because I don't know what is it well
I mean I mean to be frank we've only
been working at a campaign for 24 hours
um I I as a member of the government I I
don't think the economic strategy
couldn't change much because we need to
make sure that our economy is completely
stable so um and currently Jeremy Hunt
is the chance of exchecker and then I'll
go the chief Secretary of the Treasury
are working on an economic plan uh for
the medium term and I'm quite sure that
all the candidates will want to commit
to something like that because that's
what you know we want to make sure that
we have a stable economy to build
forward on so will brush Johnson commit
to the Jeremy Hunt plan because it feels
quite important you know if you're going
to back him say you should be the next
prime minister to know
yeah he was Boris absolutely wants a
stable financial and economic background
for the country to move forward on and
to me
um and obviously you don't we don't know
what um as a campaign team that's only
been formed 24 hours and been making uh
uh telephone calls you know we've not
had privy information as to what that
might look like and or should we have
but
um I'm a as a member of the government I
think Jeremy Hunt's plan is probably the
best one in town
you should know though shouldn't you if
you're like going around calling people
asking them to put their faith in Boris
you should know exactly what is an
economic plan is shouldn't you I mean
the bank of England have to step in to
stop a run on Pension funds recently
yeah and then but the economic plan that
will have will be based on stability for
the economy um but as I say the only
plan that's been worked on currently
with all the detail that you need to
have an echolite plan is the one that
Jeremy Hunt's working on now okay um I
want to talk a little bit more about
what a Boris uh Premiership could mean
we had Steve Baker on the program uh at
the beginning of the show he's backing
Rishi sunak he said that it would be a
disaster if Bosch Johnson would be prime
minister because of the Privileges
committee he said he couldn't rule out
voting against the Prime Minister if he
felt that he had misled Parliament he
said that other conservator and peas
would be in the same situation you know
at a time when the country is in the
situation that it is after all that the
conservative party had put it through
over the last couple of months is it
really responsible to put in power
someone who could end up being found
guilty of misleading Parliament and
suspended from Parliament as a result
yeah I mean let's put all this into some
context so um firstly uh Boris was happy
for the Privileges committee
investigation to be set up you know a
conservative party member MPS did not
have to vote on that
um secondly he's very you know he's he's
been working over the summer he's you
know he's absolutely sure
um that he's going to be exonerated
thirdly he's you know we are very happy
for the Privileges committee to continue
its work we he wants the Privileges
committed to continuous work because he
he believes he will be exonerated as do
I
um and then I don't know what this vote
is that people are talking about
immediately as we get back privileges
committee has not started its work uh
for uh properly yet there's a long way
to go
um yeah evidence will be taken
um I'm sure there'll be one or two press
press uh columns written about it and
I'm sure Sophie you'll have some time on
your show dedicated to it um
but uh only if the Privileges committee
uh were to find him uh uh in some way in
error would there be any any worry about
a penalty at all and I don't believe
that would be the case so you're talking
I think about many many months
um down the line that it's just a
theoretical possibility
no we can't you know just underplay the
importance of of this they can we as
well you know Boris Johnson quit when
his own MPS lost confidence in him he
was the only serving prime minister to
have been found to have broken the law
you know people like William Hague for
example saying on Friday he risks
sending the party into a death spiral is
he really the answer to the problems the
conservative party now faces well
there's I mean there's polling today
that suggests very strongly that he is
um you know without any campaigning just
um uh uh flying back um from the
Dominican Republic
um there's polling that suggests that he
pulls us back within 26 seats if there
was a general election called
um tomorrow of Labor and that's without
him saying async wouldn't stop polling
so yeah according to that public so but
yeah Boris Johnson is unbelievably
popular with the public he can connect
with the public like a few other
politicians of my generation and I doubt
we'll see any anyone like him again he
has a mandate with the British people he
won the 2019 election with a massive
80-seat majority unheard of uh since the
times of Margaret with Thatcher and Tony
Blair and this is you know this is a man
who actually does know how to govern who
can govern and given the chance would
happily govern again
you know things are very different back
in 2019 though as I'm sure you will
admit when Boris Johnson did win at that
election uh not just because he was up
against Jeremy corbyn as well you know
Boris Johnson actually had positive
approval ratings for a few months you
know by January this year there were
minus 52 that's lower than Theresa May
or David Cameron ever got that's that's
why your colleagues got rid of him
um well I mean if we were four or five
points behind in the polls um as well
um but I mean
when you when you get when you get to a
general election everybody's mind
concentrates on uh first of all special
the country and indeed who you know what
sort of
um uh prime minister uh they would like
now Boris Johnson the show has
demonstrated that he can
um touch like the Heineken of British
politics you know his popularity can
touch anywhere in the country whatsoever
can get and absolutely anywhere get
votes from anywhere he is still that
popular
um now he can demonstrate um to the
Parliamentary party you know he's a man
that everybody wants to talk to he's a
man that lights up a room when he comes
into it so yeah he can he can pull this
around and he'll have he has already a
track record of delivery on brexit on
covid
um on on dealing with the uh the first
ramifications that flowed from Putin's
illegal invasion of
Ukraine so there's a whole host of
things delivery and indeed hope for the
future that Boris gives us
would you like to see him offer the
chancellorship to Rishi Scenic if he
does make it
I I'd very much like the two of them and
as I say penny as well because I think
Penny's got a great is is a great talent
um and we have got some amazing uh great
amazing talents in our in our party I'd
like to see everybody work together so
we can um move on from the position
we're in now
I mean Jacob Reed smoke has been
pictured with the slogan Boris or bust
that doesn't sound like someone who is
working together does it uh yeah but
that I gotta say uh our mini campaign
does not have an official slogan or
anything like that so that was just
something someone else had mocked up
Jacob used it um I I think that's a bit
unfortunate obviously but it's just uh
you can't stop people being enthusiastic
about Boris okay and now I want to ask
you a question with your Northern
Ireland hat on you're obviously the
Secretary of State for Northern Ireland
and you've said uh that you know there
will be an election triggered uh if the
uh assembly there doesn't manage to get
up and running uh you of course are
currently a Secretary of State for an
online and that could change in a couple
of days time whoever is in that job what
do you think we need to see now
um well so the election would be uh
would be cool because actually it's a
legal requirement um it's it's primary
legislation that um if six months passes
without an executive uh reforming for
the normal nine assembly
um after the previous election then an
election has to be called so it's
actually a legal requirement to call it
a one minute past midnight on the 28th
of October
um and so whoever sits in the seats of
the Northern Ireland secretary at that
time and I truly hope it's me but who
knows
um uh you will be in that position so
the the Democratic Universe party uh
have got an opportunity to come back in
it's really important actually uh that I
I think that they do because there's so
many domestic issues in Northern Ireland
that would be helped
um by their re-entry into the executive
and they've got some really talented
politicians themselves who can help sort
those uh those issues out
um so there is a choice that people can
make to stop there being election but
it's got to be made by elective
representative moment going back in to
that assembly so without that
um the secretary from Northern Ireland
would have to call an election this week
and just finally while I've got you
um why was Boris Johnson on holiday when
Parliament was sitting
um well it would have been slipped so uh
so yeah uh I think you'll find um
a number we've got a couple of former
Prime Ministers uh now sitting on the
boat benches and because they are truly
big beasts in our parliamentary system
uh as a chief whip it's one of them asks
you if they could have some time off to
do something you'd normally say yes what
does slip didn't mean you mean he would
have got permission to go off on a on a
nice hobby yes you get permission to go
away
okay so again we very much commissioned
so campaigning you know that sort of
thing yeah
permission to go on holidays as usual
then
it's it's it's a thing
okay all right uh Chris Heaton Harris
thank you very much for being on the
program uh today
my pleasure
Chris Heaton house there saying that
Boris Johnson does have uh the numbers
he is confident to make it through onto
the ballot well whoever manages to get
the top job the absolute first thing in
an extremely difficult intro for the new
conservative leader will be the economy
the chancellor Jeremy Hunt has already
warned of decisions of an eye-watering
difficulty and a combination of spending
cuts and tax Rises are expected
imminently with a fiscal statement due
in just eight days time so how much room
for maneuver is there for whoever wins
the contest we're joined now by the
former commercial Secretary of the
Treasury under prime minister's David
Cameron and Theresa May Lord Jim O'Neill
who is also the chief Economist at
Goldman Sachs uh concept appear now sits
as a cross Venture in the House of Lords
thank you very much for being with us at
our program today
well it's the great Grudge Match isn't
it you know Boris Johnson versus Richie
sunac but you know behind the soap opera
things are really really serious the new
prime minister will inherit an extremely
difficult economic situation and who
would you like to see uh become the next
prime minister
well and in your intro you described me
as a cross-bencher so I think uh
consistent with me sitting on the
independent cross benches I I shouldn't
really have an opinion on such matters I
suppose but
um I I think if you look at what's uh
each has said about these issues in the
past uh Rishi obviously would be the
safer power hands uh and in many ways
what Jeremy hunts has announced since he
appeared on the scene what is it only
just over a week ago it seems forever
um it's effectively what Rishi suggested
would have to be the case when he was
campaigning in the summer so I think
certainly fair enough to say that the
markets are conditioned
uh for for the kind of view that Rishi
would currently have whereas with Boris
As We Know
uh we don't quite know what you're going
to get let's say
yeah it's interesting isn't it uh you
know Chris Heaton Harris are saying that
he thinks that Bros will stick to the
Jeremy Hunter plan but we haven't really
as she said uh had a nailed down
explanation of what that economic Vision
could be do you think that might make
the markets a bit nervous
there are lots of other issues going on
on Friday I I read summaries about the
markets being uh worried again because
of the appearance of Boris in the in the
campaign but there's also a lot going on
in the US and in China and also uh
tricky issues looming in Japan with
financial markets so
you have to be careful some days big
moves happen that affect our markets
that have nothing to do with us but all
of that said the markets because of the
remarkable self-inflicted damage of the
past few weeks are looking for fiscal
credibility in the UK and
the sort of they were assuming until
Thursday we were going to get it but uh
it's very hard to see that if Boris
appears on the scene first of all Jeremy
Hunt would necessarily stay as
Chancellor and if Boris would want to go
back to everything he said
um as it's been a consistent theme of
money how how can he do all these things
about spending everywhere and keep taxes
low and they don't really go together
and at the end of the the day that the
big issue facing any leader in the
foreseeable future is we have a conflict
between
uh Promises of taxes to be as low as
possible a very strong public appetite
for spending and fiscal credibility and
and some things have to give obviously
and then on top of that uh and I really
do think it's very sad given the
self-inflicted mess there is an urgent
need to somehow get out of this product
so let's see uh trap that the country's
in and and somebody do something to uh
take because announced a bit and I I did
personally Advocate to the treasury SEC
select committee earlier this year that
[Music]
unfortunately it does look like that
link we're having a few problems with a
link to uh Jim O'Neill there
unfortunately we will let you know if
that is re-established okay well let's
try again cross our fingers
technical Gremlins all over the place
but we can see you so let's come back
excellent good stuff you were just
talking about the sort of economic
picture
um what how big is you know the black
hole in the public finances and how do
you think it should be dealt with
that's a short term because of what's
happened the country is going to have to
uh undertake fiscal consolidation and
fiscal credibility Above All Else
uh and so something along the lines of
what the obr was set out and what Jeremy
Hunter said he's going to do I don't
really see how we can Veer away from
that without uh an even worse reaction
from the financial markets unfortunately
um sadly it's only because of the the
nature and the style in which the
self-inflicted mess of the previous
leadership brought it around because we
do need to do something to to boost our
productivity rate and I think there is a
case for a different approach to fiscal
uh Behavior particularly a case of a
much bigger government spending and at
some point some government is going to
have to do that in this country but I
think that option is off the table for
whoever wins the leadership in the next
few days here
you know you've been you know a big
backer of the leveling up agenda you
know your Vice chair of the northern
Powerhouse are you worried what spending
cuts could mean to that agenda
well I'm worried uh specifically about
that of course and I'm also worried more
broadly that it it sort of takes us back
to where we were in style uh to 2010 and
there are there are lots of major
economic challenges
um including obviously the the financing
of the Health and Social needs as well
as these Mammoth Geographic inequalities
in the country and we're only going to
be able to really solve them if if a
very patient source of investment
Capital appears and that very patient
source is the government but
uh I can't see given the damage the
government has created for itself and
for the country's reputation how they
can execute such a program in the very
short term without much bigger tax
increases but what what I think should
also therefore be happen happen as soon
as some kind of proper uh stability and
political stability and fiscal
credibility is established is this some
kind of request for a review of the
fiscal policy framework where you
actually as opposed to just announced
some random thing you ask all the expert
players like the obr maybe the bank of
England uh is there scope for having
let's call it a modern version of the
Gordon Brown uh Golden Rule where
government can invest more because
that's the only way we're going to get
out of this productivity trap in my
opinion but doesn't that mean more
borrowing which is what got us into this
mess in the first place well I I of
course it does but I think there is a
very clear case
uh for more borrowing for investment
spending where
I would guess most economists you would
quiz would believe there are what
economists would describe are positive
multiplier effects which means the
future growth performance from that
investment spending will benefit quite
clearly
and you'd have to do it in a really
sound transparent and approved way by
the likes of the obr otherwise it would
be problematical but uh I think the case
at some stage to go down that path is
very very strong but I don't think it's
an option that faces this incoming
leader because of the mess
his or her colleagues have created for
them
what do you think is likely to happen to
mortgages and also perhaps house Rises
house prices as well uh you know in the
in the short term when we well I I think
the the best that could be said is if
uh whoever wins follows through with
let's call it Jeremy Hunt style promises
mortgage rates will now not go up as
much as they almost definitely would
have done two weeks ago and if you look
carefully at what happened in the
markets over the course of the week uh
there's been a slight reduction in the
in the in the peak of interest rates in
the next 12 months that the markets have
had priced and if you look at what a
couple of Bank of England NPC members
said towards the end of the week they
they were implying I emphasized implying
that they might not tighten as much as
otherwise if we restore fiscal
credibility
okay thank you very much indeed really
fascinating uh to talk and to get your
take on all of that thank you thanks for
having me on
well it's been a program dominated by
the conservative party leadership
contest so far but let's turn to labor
shall we the party has extended its
record poll leads even further this week
but how will the opposition react to yet
another new conservative party leader
and who do they fear the most well we
can talk now to the shadow leveling up
secretary at least and Andy who was in
Wigan uh today thank you for being with
us this morning well the drama of the
concert of leadership contest has really
been about Boris Johnson hasn't it uh
Willie won't you run is he flying back
from holiday in the Caribbean telling
colleagues is up for it you know are we
all back within the Boris Johnson soap
opera
I mean the drama is just incredible the
only thing it's not been about is the
country and meanwhile you've got people
whose mortgage payments have gone up by
more than 500 pounds on average a month
you've got people paying a very very
heavy price for this ongoing chaos in
the Tory party and whether it's Boris
Johnson Rishi sunak or any of the other
contenders who've been floating around
this weekend essentially what the Tory
party is about to do is bring the
arsonists in to try and put out the fire
that they started it's just not good
enough we need not just to change a
prime minister we need a change of
government
um someone in your party though would
say that Boris Johnson is actually the
greatest threat to labor I just want to
have a look you know this is Angela
Reyna on LBC in July Boris had this
Teflon coating it's like a little magic
where he was able to get through to the
public Boris had so much going for him
he got an 80 seat majority and the
country was really behind him Here's
Lucy Powell an in-house magazine Boris
in his Heyday was a very formidable
campaigner who was able to reach parts
of the country that other conservatives
hadn't and wouldn't be able to reach do
you agree with your colleagues
well he undeniably won a big majority at
the last election and then very very
quickly the wheels came off the wagon I
wouldn't trust Boris Johnson to run a
bath let alone run the country he
degraded under Bay Star politics he lost
all of that Goodwill from the country
and from his own colleagues in a very
short space of time it's extraordinary
watching Tory MPS who put in letters of
no confidence in him just a few weeks
ago saying he wasn't fit to hold the
highest office now talking openly about
trying to bring him back it's a sign of
absolute utter desperation in the Tory
party it's time that the public were
brought back into this conversation
because there is a clear choice between
a Tory party that have crashed the
economy and presided over 12 years of
chaos bringing our National Health
Service to its knees and soaring crime
rates and a labor party that could bring
calm and stability back to the markets
be careful and sensible with every
single penny that we spend because it's
people's money and they haven't got a
lot of it
you know you obviously want a general
election that is very clear but you know
with your sort of public responsibility
hat on you know you're talking there
about how difficult things are for
people we do use stability it's been a
difficult couple of months to say the
very very least who do you hope becomes
the next prime minister next week
well kirst armor it's the obvious answer
because if we had her but he's not going
to be the next prime minister next week
is he
well but the truth is it makes
absolutely no difference at all who the
Tory party choose because even before
they crashed the economy and left
working people paying the price we'd had
12 years of low growth and the highest
tax burden on working people in 70 years
they haven't got a clue how to set this
right because they're the people who
created this problem in the first place
we've got to get good jobs back into
every community in this country and get
the economy firing on all cylinders
again we could become a world leader in
clean energy there are a million good
jobs on the road to Net Zero and we will
invest to bring them here you just heard
Jim O'Neill saying there's a strong case
for investment to rebuild the fabric of
this country from the ground up that is
what is at stake for the for this
country we've got a clear choice to make
and that's why we're arguing for a
general election not because there's a
lot at stake for the labor party but
because there's so much at stake for the
country
um you say that you know it wouldn't
make any difference to the next
conservative prime minister is I mean
that's not really true is it like I get
that you really want kissed armor in
there I get your frustrations that you
know there's another at least a contest
going on without a general election but
obviously it would make a difference who
wins the contest wouldn't it for the
country
I don't think so when you've got a
government that is completely out of
energy and out of ideas whoever becomes
leader of the conservative party in the
next week or so is going to inherit the
same problem it's not just that they've
crashed the economy and now they've got
to find money from somewhere whether
it's raising taxes on working people or
um cutting Public Services as Jeremy
Hunt has been floating it's not just
that they've got a very divided Tory
party it's that they've got the same
tired failed ideology that got us into
this mess in the first place the idea
that you can grow the economy by
investing in a small handful of people
in a small number of sectors in one
small corner of the country and the
benefits of that will trickle down to
the rest of us it just demonstrably has
not worked we say that every person and
every place has a contribution tonight
to the future of this country and that's
why we're going to invest to bring those
good jobs to Britain get money back into
people's pockets and get the economy
growing again
okay um well let's have a look at
Labor's economic plan then shall we you
know your sort of positioning yourselves
as the party of a fiscal responsibility
we know that there is a physical
tightening on its way uh really whoever
wins uh but certainly if Rishi zunak
does the spending review no longer
applies departments have been asked to
find efficiency savings would labor
spend more money on public services than
the conservatives
well we've already set out plans to get
money into the National Health Service
by scrapping non-dom tax status which we
think will raise about three billion
pounds and spending roughly half of that
on getting more Health visitors more
training more doctors and nurses into
the NHS because we Face a crisis this
winter we've got more than a million
people on waiting lists and we've got to
do something to act now but we're what
we're really interested in is how you
can reform Public Services you know
Jeremy Hunt who's currently the
chancellor is the person who failed to
invest in the National Health Service
didn't bring it up to speed with
digitalization so that we're doing we're
spending more to do less that's why
we've said we'll prioritize when we do
borrow we're not going to borrow for
day-to-day spending we're not going to
live out with our means but we are going
to prioritize getting investment into
the economy so that we can get Public
Services working far more efficiently
and help to people who need it at the
moment they need it not waiting until
people hit crisis point before we
intervene Which is far more costly and
so so damaging
so is that yes then you would spend more
money on public services than the
conservatives
well well we're not we're not going to
borrow to fund day-to-day spending it's
the consequences of doing that when you
haven't costed it and you don't know how
you're going to pay for it are very
severe we've just seen that they
literally crashed the economy with a
multi-billion pound package that they
couldn't cost they couldn't fund and
ultimately all that help that was
promised those energy help with energy
bills they just couldn't deliver when we
make promises we intend to keep them and
that's why every single thing that we
propose between now and the next general
election will be fully costed fully
funded and will publish an assessment in
government of the impact that that will
have on the wider economy as well okay
because obviously you know if everything
is going to be fully costed if you
aren't going to be borrowing from
day-to-day spending we all know there's
a big black hole in the public finances
around 40 billion pounds that's even
after Jeremy Hunt reversed at the mini
budget it was around 60 billion before
that according to the IFS would you put
up taxes in order to try and plug that
black hole
well we've already said that we would
expand the windfall tax on the big
energy producers in order to get more
money back into people's pockets and off
their energy bill sure but this is this
is the point isn't it I'm not I'm not
sorry that we're going to be careful
with people's money because it is their
money and they haven't got a lot of it
and the last thing that this country
needs is more Reckless spending when the
government has has just crashed the
economy by saying that they'll Target
tax cuts to the richest and then
couldn't work out how they were going to
pay for it of course we'll invest in our
Public Services we saved we've built the
National Health Service we created
comprehensive education in this country
and in 1997 after years of the Tories
degrading our Public Services we came in
and rebuilt them From the Ashes of the
Thatcher era of course we'll prioritize
that and that's why we said that we
would scrap non-dom status and get money
into the NHS it said that we would end
the Arcane system where you've got
police forces up and down the country
all procuring their own Services
separately which wastes a huge amount of
money and will bring those things
together in order to get more police
onto the streets through the savings
that we make there but we're going to
think creatively and smartly about how
we spend every precious Penny and we're
going to prioritize rebuilding this
country the fabric of this country from
the ground up okay
um just finally you want an election how
are you going to get one are you going
to call a vape
it's entirely up to Tory MPS now the
tragic fact is that the future of this
country lies in the hands of a small
number of people who are currently
putting party before country we're
calling on them to put country before
party and do the right thing they know
that Britain can't go on like this
everybody in this country knows that
Britain can't go on like this and it is
unconscionable that we're going to bring
back one of the old tired failed leaders
from the past in order to put out the
fire that they started we all know it's
not going to work Tori MPS know in the
heart of hearts it's not going to work
and it's time for a general election
okay thank you very much indeed Lisa and
Andy there are talking to us from Wigan
today
thank you
well that is it for this week's safety
Ridge on Sunday in a moment after the
break we're gonna be running through
today's uh interviews because there was
some pretty spicy ones on the show today
I have to say uh we will be joined by
athletic correspondent Ali fortisky here
in the studio thanks for joining us this
Sunday morning
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
the take where we take you back through
the mornings interviews with some
analysis from our political team today
we're joined by Ali fortsky so please
stay good to see you Ali what a morning
well I mean I guess the big question
today the question I want to know is
does Boris have the numbers I'll admit
I've been quite skeptical which maybe
came across on some of the interviews
this morning
um you know I think I said that you know
it's a bit like saying you've got a
girlfriend but they go to a different
school like how can we believe that when
they say he's got the numbers unless we
know who they are but he's had another
backer hasn't he yeah Nadeem zahawi this
is significant he is the chancellor to
the duchy of Lancaster senior figure in
the Tory party he's just come out on
Twitter backing Boris Johnson so that
adds to you know you've got Jacob
reesemog the dean dorries Ben Wallace
suggesting he'd back Boris these are Big
names I think it is really really
difficult to know what the numbers are
because of course we sort of publicly
have I think we're hovering where are we
now 57. he says he's got his team say
he's got more than 100 you had Chris
Heaton Harris saying that this morning
someone close to him yesterday told me
he had 102. I think what's obvious is
that every vote will count for Boris
Johnson if he does get there it could be
by one or two votes it's pretty close
isn't it it is going to be close but at
the moment we don't know for sure you
know he it it seems like he has a pretty
solid core is what people say of 60 or
so backers so this is the tweet from
nadimsa harway I'm back in Boris he got
the big course right whether it was
ordering more vaccines ahead of more
ways of covid arming Ukraine early
against the advice of some or stepping
down for the sake of unity but now
Britain needs him back we need to unite
to deliver on our Manifesto he goes on
to say it's a two two tweet thread he
says when I was Chancellor I saw a
preview of what Boris 2.0 would look
like he was contrite and honest about
this mistakes he'd learned from those
mistakes how he could run number 10 and
the country better with the unified team
behind him he is the one to lead us to
Victory and prosperity uh Nadeem zahari
there I mean it is important to say
isn't it that look Nadim zahari is one
of he's he's close to Boris Johnson
isn't it it's not a massive you know
surprise the same with Ben Wallace these
are people who know Boris Johnson well
um I guess the question is are there
enough waivers uh to that he could pick
up yeah I I think you know the thing
with Boris Johnson is he really brings
out really strong feelings on both sides
people feel passionately one way or the
other people that don't back him say
hold on this is a guy that just a few
months ago 60 ministers resigned under
would he actually be able to form a
government would he be able to get
enough good people in his team and you
know there's one person I spoke to
yesterday one MP who's really quite
upset by the idea of him coming back
some people said they'd leave the
Parliamentary party all together he is
devices but then there are divisive but
then there are those passionately back
him but yeah as you say you know could
there be some career-minded MPS that
sense that there's some momentum perhaps
and Rowing behind Boris Johnson I don't
think it would by any means be an easy
Victory as I said yeah Ali thank you so
much we're having lots more from Ali as
a show goes on um but I was just talking
about strong feelings and I have to say
there were some strong feelings on
display with our first guest this
morning Steve Baker now he was someone
who I was really interested to hear on
hear from uh he backed Boris Johnson in
2019 he was kind of instrumental really
in that Victory he was also quite
instrumental in Liz truss's Victory
along with sewella Brotherman who he
backed the first time around he then
swung in behind Liz truss so he's a big
figure among the kind of ride to the
party if you like the ERG group the
so-called group of brexit for supporting
MPS on the parties right so I was
interested to know Woody bat Boris Woody
bat Rishi
so when we got down to Rishi versus Liz
I felt we had two fantastic candidates
to offer to the membership I was backing
Liz because that was the choice which
Sue Ella and the Euro Skeptics made I
was proud to backlas but realistically
if you look at the summer I didn't
campaign very hard and that was because
I was very happy with either candidate
and the truth is that it was quite a
marginal decision for me and I'm very
proud to back Rishi this time
was she this time around according to
Steve Baker but I think what was perhaps
uh the kind of the most explosive part
of the interview I guess was when I
asked him about Boris Johnson whether or
not he would support Boris Johnson
returned to Downing streets as prime
minister let's take a listen
I've been a big fan of Boris Johnson so
many times but this isn't the time for
boris's style I mean I'm afraid the
trouble is because of the Privileges
vote Boris would be a guaranteed
disaster
indeed disaster well let's bring in Ali
at shall we now is we should give a bit
background to this shouldn't we the
Privileges vote uh is when the committee
decides whether or not he misled
Parliament yeah that's right so this all
Hearts back to party gate did Boris
Johnson knowingly mislead Parliament
when he said that no rules were broken
so they're going to be hearing evidence
from Witnesses this could drag out this
could be painful for Boris Johnson to
see people from his own team come out
and brief against him publicly and
potentially if he is founder of misled
Parliament he could even be suspended he
could even see a by-election in his seat
I mean you know we're not there yet but
that is something extraordinary that a
prime minister would have to go to and
that science coming up again again and
it was kind of extraordinary to hear
from Steve Baker who said that look he
thinks there are enough people on the
conservative benches who would vote
against Boris Johnson and he couldn't
rule it out himself either because he
said it was about people's Integrity
extraordinary and again you know brings
up strong feelings on both sides I think
the question people have is what has
Boris Johnson going to do to show that
he's actually changed and I think people
you know his relationship's always been
quite transactional and there is some
evidence now that he might not do as
well as a polls as he did last time
certainly you know the by-elections and
the polling before he he stepped down
suggests that
um Christine Harris was talking to you
saying that this is someone that lights
up the room in fact I think Steve Baker
might have said that again
but his critics will say that actually
he he's damaged goods that he is poison
in the bloodstreet of the party and they
can't deal with they can't that he is
not the person that can unite around us
let's talk a bit about the Chris Heaton
Harris interview shall we because I
thought it was quite interesting
actually I think I learned some stuff
from it um Chris Heaton Harris big hour
Boris Johnson he was his chief whip so
you know back in the time when they were
in the trenches together you know Boris
Johnson was playing on trying to work
out if he could stay it was Christine
Harris he went to him and said look you
don't have the numbers
and he now says Boris Johnson does have
the numbers but do we trust him I mean I
thought that was my ears sort of pricked
up when I heard that because as you say
you know former Chief whip someone that
knows numbers it was interesting to hear
from Lord Hayward this morning to
pollster Tori who was saying he said to
me after you know he could sort of
Scrump together and just about get over
the line it's not going to be easy but I
think it's possible
um and I think yeah Chris Heaton Harris
also yeah again talking about elections
but I think you know the big things that
have changed are Corbin and brexit and
those aren't the big factors anymore if
Boris Johnson does go to the polls yeah
let's have a quick listen to um
Christian house shall we let's have a
listen
um you know you say that you have the
numbers over 100 MPS that's what we've
been briefed as well but obviously the
the declared backers are much much lower
than that so you know we just have to
take your word for it is it a bit like
saying you know I have got a girlfriend
but you wouldn't know her she goes to a
different School
um no I mean I so the one thing I was
relatively good at as Chief whip was
numbers and
um we definitely have a a enough uh
numbers to get um well we've already
booked the appointment with Bob Blackman
the uh sector of the 1922 tomorrow so
yeah we've got the numbers
uh well he says he's so confident we're
going to find out soon aren't we Ali the
other thing I've got to ask you as well
um is we know that there were lots in
these talks last night now I thought
that maybe if Boris Johnson doesn't have
the numbers that we're going to come out
today and have some kind of deal struck
between the two men maybe they'd accept
a job in in exchange for backing the
other candidates do we know anything
about what went on well I mean it sounds
like there's no sort of clear deal I
mean certainly you know this is amazing
because this is all happening behind
closed doors they haven't even said
they're running yet the only person
who's exactly lagging behind in terms of
MPS so at least likely to be prime
minister I mean it is incredibly strange
this whole thing we do understand that
Boris Johnson and Richard C Knight spoke
last night I think there's not much love
lost between these two plenty of Boris
allies see Rishi sunak as a man that
stabbed him in the back the man that
brought about his downfall I find it
hard in the conversations I've had to
see either Boris Johnson or Richie sunac
serving in the other ones cabinet I
think they both want the top job
extraordinary stuff absolutely
extraordinary alley and as you say the
fact that we've only got one Contender
formally announced and it's all going to
start tomorrow I can't get my head
around it and only seven weeks since the
last one it's it's incomprehensible but
this time tomorrow what time is it we we
might have a sense we might know who's
actually running in this we hope we know
who's coming yeah people might say you
know Boris Johnson won't run if he
doesn't think he can actually get on the
ballot he won't want to come second
place particularly to Rishi sunak yes
that's true things are going to have to
move quite quickly because it's not long
till we we actually know uh great stuff
a really interesting to talk uh ali uh
well coming after the break we'll have
even more on the leadership contractor
that is dominating everything at this
morning
[Music]
I'm Mark Stone and I'm Sky's
correspondent based here in Washington
DC
well the plan seems to be to head to the
police station where the policeman who
fired the shots was based
anything you know his memories is all
gone
[Music]
in almost every corner this town has
been completely destroyed by the fire
I've witnessed the remarkable passion
for politics here but the anger too we
have to get Trump out of the White House
is this the moment to reform gun laws
you know it's it's easy to go to
politics but it's important it's at the
heart of the issue I I get that that's
where the media likes to go it's not
it's where many of the people we've
talked to here like to go I report on
the biggest stories from around the
world
this is a town that is effectively
encircled by the Russians
you say it's all fabrication what's
happening in butcher
destroyed my nation
foreign
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our planet
I can hear now quite a
quite up here in Jerusalem a very
violent series of confrontations here
what do you think of Isis anybody here
no the truth of Isis
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello welcome back to safety Ridge on
Sunday the take where we take you back
through the morning's interviews and
with some analysis from our political
team and myself as well and today we've
got Ali Fortescue with us on set
um so you were saying before the break
that the only declared candidate
astonishingly so far is actually Penny
mordant
um how are her numbers looking so I mean
her campaign this time around she had
great momentum in the summer at the
start she came third she got 105 MPS
backing her in the last round so she
could have made it onto the ballot but
she has just lacked momentum this time
around she's been hovering around 20
votes for about a day
um I mean people like David Davis he was
one of her key backers last time he's
now switched and he's on team Rishi so
it just feels like she's things could
change it feels like she's not going to
get there right now it's quite
interesting isn't it with uh penny more
than because as you say she's lost some
of her buckets from last time Caroline
notes another one who's where she not
her
um I just wonder do you think that it's
damaged her a bit the fact that she went
in behind Liz truss last time a lot of
her support seems to be from the kind of
one nation group you know people like
Damien green who will hear from in a
minute who back where she's sunac after
she dropped out I think that's a really
yeah I think that's a really really
interesting point I wonder if perhaps
some of those that
are probably against Liz pretty against
they I think people also just realize
that something has to change and I think
people really feel Vindicated by what
happened under Liz truss and they can
see some say that Russia United got it
right so and I think you're starting to
see people know this is going to go one
way or another and they have to get in
those camps if they're going to either
stop restaurants or stop brush you soon
at yeah and I think part of this as well
is what there isn't is some people that
feel very strongly against Penny Morden
I'd say whereas I think there are people
that certainly did feel quite strongly
against Russia see now and definitely
people that feel strongly against Boris
Johnson so I think a lot of this is they
want to stop the other person from
getting it yeah and as you say it's all
about momentum isn't it you in fact the
person who think is most likely to do
that and and if she's lagging behind a
bit I think is it going to be a wasted
vote let's have a listen to Damien green
shall we now he is one of Penny morden's
supporters he says he's in no doubt she
has got the numbers
a lot of colleagues are are not saying
for various reasons I wouldn't criticize
them for that
um but it's it's multiples of 23. I
think where would you we're confident of
I I won't reveal numbers partly because
they you know they change by the hour
they grow by the hour
um but I'm confident that the penny will
get uh over the line tomorrow you think
she'll get over 100 yes okay um so no
question of her pulling out today then
rowing in behind another candidate she's
in it to win no no she she is in it to
win Penny doesn't need to do deals to
unify the party and stabilize the
government because of what she stands
for and because of the work she's done
she can do that herself and that I think
makes her the strongest candidate
he said he was confident
I don't think he sounded that confident
what do you think you know he was saying
multiples of 20 I'm not going to get
into numbers because they change and
then grow by the
hourly sounded as you say people see the
way the wind is blowing people see
momentum
you need to show that you can get there
that there's a point in backing penny so
inevitably people that are behind her
want to show that she's doing well I
didn't think he sounded totally
convinced I don't think she is there
right now that doesn't mean that things
can't change very quickly we've seen
that happen a lot in the past but there
is pressure on her now to row in behind
one of the other candidates I think
there's definitely pressure for her to
row in behind Richie sooner there's no
indication at all that she would do that
um but she has been interviewed this
morning she has come out and said that
she's not standing down so there's no
hint she's going to do that anytime soon
but I think that pressure is going to
mount over the next 24 hours yeah I did
wonder actually if she would you know
decide to become the king maker and
perhaps in a return for like a nice job
in a future cabinet but it doesn't seem
like she will yeah and as you were
saying you know I think she was
criticized by some people for rowing in
behind Liz trust last time around so
would she do that again if she's looking
at a senior job
I I from the conversation I was having
yesterday evening with someone on her
team I can't see her stepping down but
as things get close and it becomes more
obvious you might not make it onto the
ballot maybe yesterday we could see a
last minute intervention yeah it will be
interesting uh to see that for sure
um Damien green also made the point
didn't he uh that look um it's not good
for the conservative party to bypass the
members and not have a contest it's not
good for them to be seen to be stitching
up the process and he was effectively
saying that look you know if the deal
has been done which as you say we
probably don't think it has between
Boris Johnson and Richie suno that's not
a great look you know how much pressure
do you think there will be on whoever is
the next leader to to go to the public
to call an election
so labor obviously want to see that
happen the SNP want to see that happen
the live Dems want to see that happen
unsurprisingly you know labor Riding
High in the polls they know that they
would potentially do really well in an
election so I think what might happen
now is obviously whoever becomes prime
minister it would be like a turkey
voting for Christmas they would not push
ahead with that because they know it
would be bad for the Tories
um I think if it becomes clear that
whoever becomes the next prime minister
still can't keep this party together we
still see chaotic scenes I think there
is so much of poison in the blood that
this is a Tory party that is
ungovernable basically then that is when
these calls for a general election might
become deafening yeah well let's talk
about some of those calls for general
election uh because we talked to Lisa
and Andy on the program as well labeled
shadowed leveling up at secretary to get
her thoughts on the contest
whether it's Boris Johnson Rishi sunak
or any of the other contenders who've
been floating around this weekend
essentially what the Tory party is about
to do is bring the arsonists in to try
and put out the fire that they started
it's just not good enough we need not
just to change a prime minister we need
a change of government
there you go Lisa nandy on the program
today it's interesting though isn't it
because whoever is the next prime
minister it's going to be an awful job
isn't it I have to say you know you look
at the a 40 billion pound black hole
that we think we have you know Lisa
nandi's talking about you know another
windfall tax that's another 8 billion
but that leaves another what 32 billion
to to fill and Boris Johnson again you
know talking about the Mandate from the
2019 election well things have changed
since then it's gonna be very difficult
to deliver on that Manifesto with the
economic Outlook that we've seen out yes
absolutely right I mean Boris Johnson I
think you know is someone that likes big
spending projects likes is talked
obviously a lot about leveling up that
was a big part of his Manifesto he likes
to spend money on things that will you
know be part of his legacy obviously the
economic picture has changed since he
was prime minister will he be someone
that can Comfort the markets will he be
someone that can turn the tide on the
economy I mean I I I think people a lot
of people would say that Richard is the
one that can steady the economy so we
don't know you know what his of new
pitch will be for that I think what is
also you know interesting is the fact
that
our government Department you know we're
in the middle of cost of living crisis
our government Department's able to
function I was talking to a couple of
civil servants last week who were saying
they're just they're just waiting to
find out who's going to be their next
secretary of state and this was before
Liz trusted even gone it's quite hard to
actually get the business of government
done when you don't know who's going to
be your secretary of state at the end of
the week when you're gonna have to brief
someone all over again so I think it and
there are people who say the Tories
can't get into the habit of getting rid
of their leaders once you do it once
does that mean that you know old Boris
isn't working let's do it again
I think there are people who think this
is a party that obviously needs to come
together but that actually the important
job of running the country isn't
happening I'm gonna have a quick Listen
to Lord Jim O'Neill we asked about the
economic situation he's had experience
in the treasury and also in the northern
Powerhouse let's listen
consistent with me sitting on the
independent cross benches I I shouldn't
really have an opinion on such matters I
suppose but
um I I think if you look at what's uh
each has said about these issues in the
past uh Rishi obviously would be the
safer power hands I think
certainly fair enough to say that the
markets are conditioned
uh for for the kind of view that Rishi
would currently have whereas with Boris
As We Know
uh we don't quite know what you're going
to get let's say
that's an understatement there's no you
don't know what you're going to get with
Boris Johnson
I mean it is incredible just to take
stock of where we are tomorrow we will
know who is on the final ballot I think
there's two options really either a
coronation for Rishi sunac or former
prime minister and the chancellor that
brought him down head-to-head up against
the membership
I don't it's unless penny more than has
a miraculous recovery it's an absolutely
extraordinary isn't it it really is and
I actually did think that by this time
we might know if it was going to be a
coronation or a contest and we still
don't know do we to be honest I think
that maybe gives you a sense that the
numbers could be
closely you know yeah potentially Ali
thank you very much indeed great to have
you on the show uh today well that is it
from Sophie Ridge on Sunday the tape
this morning uh what a week it's been I
just can't even get my head around it we
will have the podcast uh very shortly
with you that would be with myself Scott
Beasley a producer and Liz Bates a
political correspondent around lunchtime
in the meantime hope to see you
Wednesday night 9 p.m for safety Ridge
on Sunday the tape where we will not
Sunday sacred to take on Wednesday I
should say you can tell it's been a week
can't you great to have you with us see
you next time
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]